es wird übertragen
herzlich willkommen zu meinem ersten
live stream auf youtube heute hatten wir
machen heute eine dr bieber live
challenge ich wollte das heute
eigentlich ein video machen aber den
ganzen tag auf dem event von youtube
will nicht mehr ganz auf dem event
deswegen habe ich nicht geschafft das
video zu schneiden für euch deswegen
darf wir machen das einfach mal im live
stream
das ist ein großes experiment und zwar
funktioniert das heute so wir haben hier
doch darüber haben diesen patienten hier
er ist referent dr er hat also
verschiedene dinge drin die eigentlich
da rein gehören ein apfel zb hier
darunter ein stück toast brot ein
schraubenschlüssel selbstverständlich
auch ein gummiband im bein und da muss
man ihm helfen leute müssen wir auch
unsere helfer muss man dem ganz einfach
helfen und wir machen das folgendermaßen
wir werden reihum doch darüber spielen
so und der jeweilige verlierer muss dann
sagen ob er entweder auf eine wahrheits
frage schon beantwortet oder eine strafe
die auf gesundheit kommt macht wie
könnte ich das erste mal wahrheit und
straff fragen quasi überlegen und die
dann posten sobald ich mich machen kommt
das ist okay ich würde sagen fängst du
an die leipziger okay okay okay okay was
ist ein ich glaub ich nehme an dass
nicht ganz die sie so ich sehe dass hier
gerade
ich will ja nicht sagen aber ich bin da
ziemlich guter junge war einfach super
ok dann guck mal was nehme ich denn
jetzt hat dieses gummiband ist mega
schwierig es ist ein spiel das wir
schätzen oder vor allem es kommt ja mega
darauf an wie die einzelnen
plastikstücke in dem moment gerade
liegen und wir alle nicht so gut
man darf hier nicht verschieben erklärte
bräuchten den schmetterling
ich hatte fast draußen ist
runtergefallen und dann kommt schon
kommt ein kopf an kopf ja das sieht
genommen ja ja ja ich werde nicht sagen
dass jetzt unser leistungs oder sogar
untersagt
und dann hast du auch ich mache das für
dich mal live reihe kriegt hier haben
ist eine mensch aber ich nenne das
gummiband komm komm komm schon früher
über drei weiter und den ex frau man
könnte was denkt ist ein kinderspiel
es ist ein kinderspiel dass das packen
wir live man ja challenges die struggles
die man im echten leben durchlebt jeden
tag
okay okay was haben wir ja die haben
jetzt drei dinger raus und der rest
liegt leute sensationell scheiße selbst
nicht alles glauben dass man so fast
quer kreis
oder oder irgendwie in diese ganz schräg
dabei ist total unmöglich weil du kannst
du kannst du im leben wenn ich das ich
glaube nämlich ich glaube nämlich leute
schaut mir okay ich glaube ich nehme den
knochen da drüben und das ist fucking
risky er
sobald das guck mal da klingt schon der
deutsche leute mitspielen heute so
schnell dass ein nein es geht da noch
was geht nicht raus ich wollte einfach
nur nicht der erste sein der irgendwas
war als büro es geht nicht ich glaube es
geht weiter ich würde dir du kriegst
dieses ding nicht an dem in der mitte
heraus ist physikalisch unmöglich trotz
immer okay okay wahrheit oder bestrafung
okay leute ihr könnt jetzt in jetzt
einfach live in den chats schreiben was
wir machen sollen und dann schauen wir
mal 1 55 monatlich sagen auf jeden fall
sagen nichts popo clubs eier essen
steele apfel mehr den teffer essen
übrig dieser knochen hier dieser knochen
da hat mich fackeln getötet alter diese
dreckige außerdem sind
danke dass wir gerne haben und 50 cent
pfeffer wir haben die wm wie machst du
das also immer glauben vielleicht ja
auch vergabe schön pfeffer drauf das ist
das schon
das ist so gut wie man so auf drei liter
irgendwas tut weil das ist richtig
gestört und bleibt zu 1
[Musik]
sie ist einfach so weiter was ich auch
so auszusetzen hier ein bisschen was
anderes gar keine lust zu bringen wo ein
ok kommen und ich hab gar keine lust
jetzt zu verkraften hat das ok eiskalter
motto das ist auch nicht machbar
wo man hätte zwar aber freunde freunde
jetzt mal ernsthaft
bei mir hier lieber alter okay an dieser
stelle möchte ich gerne bitten gemacht
hat dass auch yahoo hat das ist auch wie
wie das ist richtig spannend
das ist einfach so ein kleines nicht
wieder einzufrieren
ok ja dann war natürlich wie wird das
richtige ja dann mach ich dich gerade
selbst um salz steckt die handelsketten
gehabt lok güsten salz essen schon wird
man april mittel was das salz esslöffel
clou das wäre hart wird sich aber als ob
wir hier in unserem haushalt sind hätten
selbst haben wir auch nicht wahr
du kannst du auch über schnupfen haben
herzlich willkommen zum anderen
youtube-video zehn treffer in seinem
körper aufnehmen kollaborationen freunde
dich geben wenn ihr wollt dass ich mir
das so einfach meine tabletten wegnehmen
das reicht schon stabil
[Gelächter]
öffentlich ist
[Musik]
schöner in diesem youtube lassen
diese lampe hat sich schon so oft wie
ich bin dir aus weniger ist und ich bin
so auf diese scheiße gelaufen alter wenn
es so fucking brok das ist so prof
weiter geht's jetzt weiter geht's heute
geht's mir geht's super die augen tränen
nicht nase ist nicht so gesund aus ok
ich glaube ich habe mal dieses toastbrot
hier aus dem bauch jasid gerade echten
gerhard rabus schieben das ist wirklich
gut
okay okay leute sind ja das ja dieses
kleine tost drecks brot richtet ich höre
das fest gewährt festgeklebt das nicht
konnte
derzeit ist auch deshalb so ganz gut aus
aber wir müssen natürlich fair play
ja das ist okay total sommer müssen
durchmischen
naja wenn man mal sehen wir heute auch
mal ein paar kasse behalten und edward
cullen club will abdecken dass ich keine
mal eine banane sechs sekunden fragen
single singe heute exklusiv würden heute
die weiter eine gans gefragt ich bin ein
leute jetzt gerade bin ich noch single
aber so eine grenze zwischen single und
[Applaus]
das sind die exklusiven effekt so die
wissen die allerwenigsten alter die sind
ja mittlerweile nicht zu spaßen
also dass daraus bekommen
nervenkitzel pur
na da du wirst du kannst offen
konzentration und jura studium alter das
geht über 35 das ist mir die ziemlich
egal was zu helfen
wie habt ihr zuerst gehört leute macht
yoga studio jetzt muss ich halt gemerkt
erst so wurde operieren geweckt dass man
bald werden egal den nerven von brüsten
also okay damit ist nichts an der reihe
der du bist die leicht verschnupft heute
nicht mehr sagen ja ich glaube wo habe
ich neben versagt da habe ich versagt
jedes mal die nummer gesehen gerade eine
wahrheit ich hab kein bock auf die
pflege bis dahin das ist schlecht
entwendet
die sache ist beim leisten weshalb die
ganzen dummheit einfach ungefiltert okay
die wahrheit ist ja ich weiß ding ist
von seinen zuschauern kennen mich nicht
wirklich viele glaube ich deswegen alle
doch die wir alle alle leute aus der
arbeit für den fonds
die schüler muss die wahrheit raus aber
heute übertreibt nicht so es könnte zu
krass sein
diese fragen kann so krankengeld wieder
habe ich darauf gewesen dass leute dann
hat dein erstes mal mit vor der frage
wie es geht das geht nach wenn ich
online bin heute einfach kürzlich
zugelassen
260 glaube ich so dass guter alter um
den los
man sagt okay gut dann dicker dieser
mensch wir müssen habe ich da wo wir
verpacken die dinger rausnehmen weil so
schaffen wir das niemals oder müsse sich
wird dennoch meister nächste dran erst
heute allein hier noch ein zwei drei
vier fünf sechs glaubt ja ein bisschen
seines durch machen so ich guck mal was
das geht das geht dann klar das sind
schon die dinger wo der hund ist
unmöglich das schlüsselspiel der der
schraube ist es da da habt ihr auch
schon verkauft
aber ich habe auch schon bei dem
toastbrot verkaufen da okay ich glaube
dem ist hausbau machst machst du dir da
ich glaube ich nehme mir ist toastbrot
hier leute ja mal dass mainz man ganz
ehrlich leute was hat dieser bastard
gemacht ja was würdet ihr ein apfel okay
das herz ist auch gebrauchtes ok
gebrochenes herz
sonst droht hier der ifa kingsbridge den
schmetterling brot und ein gummiband
krise hat ein pferd hin bei vorbei habt
ihr ja auch leute hat den heute habt ihr
ein pferd im bein trabi hast du fertig
bist ja okay so
heute kannst du dich dreht das war für
dich komm mal von der seite
das fühlt sich gut an die java ist ja
was geht sagt keiner von euch gefallen
ist ja dass jung ist das ist so safe
alter spiele oder das lag dort einfach
anders als eben das kann auch sein kann
es auch sein mag es nicht so toll jetzt
langsam scheint ja wobei ich irgendwann
ja jetzt habe ich kenne kann ich auch
nicht ja ich habe dann zwei mal
hintereinander versagen ich weiß nicht
mal das herz ist komplett hier kein ding
ding ok schraubenschlüssel
schraubenschlüssel nennen das
millimeterarbeit aber freunde keinen
millimeter nein lieber zwei millimeter
sein ministerjob profikoch reduzieren
ich bin mit der hand ging
du hast ja das muss ich auch nicht
einmal konstant muss man schon kommen
schon dann bin ich ja eben vielleicht
auch ich darf nicht lassen
den kann man da nicht greifen denke ich
und die lampe diese liebesbeziehung
ich glaube okay die ganze so unmöglich
dieses ding wahrheit oder pflicht oder
gar nicht aber durch einen ganzen kopf
renten kommen meine pflicht
[Musik]
von ihr kommt treibt nicht nur die
abwehr kommt hat das gehört jetzt zu
hart weißt du was mit menschen macht
hand in hand ins klo
ich habe mir ja das ist so aber er hat
es anstandslos gemacht aber so macht das
ja so macht man mal das heißt ja denn so
macht ja nix zu tun warum ich ins klo
greifen sind oder es liegt so fucking
nach kanada sogleich ein pkw kommen
leute wollten die alten vertrag von
denen die kriege in den abfall
wir leben ja nicht er was dir diese
seite ja nicht so gut er mach ich habe
dann zwei miteinander verstehen und
jetzt sind wir sind so gut wie immer
über der so okay jetzt wirds langsam
richtig ernst egal was wir haben den
schraubenschlüssel endlich atypischen
bekehren und den hunden den kriegst du
nicht raus mit den komischen dübel da
und deshalb erst herz ist ich glaube ich
glaube der flügel
grübel der best-of-platte funktionieren
wobei die man musste auch gut drehen
die freiheit
die politik ist das licht oder erwartet
ein guter job ist ein surfer die augen
meiner trauer war es brennt schlecht
oder was vielleicht leute vielleicht
richtig knackig das will niemand die
wagen lenken und trinken essen die augen
ja habe ich schon einen apfel mit salz
habe ich gelesen
ein film mit der hand haben wir etwa als
ob wir haben nicht mal weg und schafft
es nicht ein zu dicker wartete dinge du
glaubst du glaubst es kam was kam weil
wir machen kommen die einfach aus dem
kombi und zwar du kannst mir ein salz
abservieren ja kein dicker aber ich
werde auch noch die lampe ablecken
einfach heute von geburt zu dieser lampe
[Musik]
nämlich rasiert die türe ja ok
doppelbestrafung jetzt einfach weil ich
komplett verpackt habe leute danach aber
immer noch so deutlich ich höre hier die
atlas hier brennt beim saugen den brands
einfach herzlich willkommen zu den
tagesthemen
ich sage euch den köstlichsten apfel der
welt mithalten
ok jetzt eine kleine portion guten
appetit feuer ist es auf jeden fall so
kann man seinen ersten stern kann man ja
aber wenig leute dann wurde auslöser wie
main kanal gefertigt habe ich und du
kommst ist kommt man so schön jetzt sofa
im auge sein leben oder läuft das nicht
nur bei dir ich danke euch nicht mit der
handpuppe mit meiner neuen 5er soll das
immer noch sperrt man hat einfach einen
kompletten mondmann was keine seife
leute heute für die gelegt und sei
abgestürzt macht einfach nicht davon
abraten körper aber das salz und
vitamine aber schmelzen bringen
ok jetzt geht man noch heute
weißt du noch mal die lampe kommt noch
ok aber nicht genau sagen
dort jemanden friedensangebot an dich
ich bin in den letzten 80 stunden und 46
mal nicht gestoßen
ich weiß dass es auch von der kampf
gesagt die auf mich zu gehandelt und ich
wollte einfach sagen wollen sie einfach
den krieg beenden
beide stellen die geht jetzt einen
kurzen firmen und beenden steht geben
und dann werden sie durch
ich glaube es richtig und dann habt ihr
denke die jetzt mit mir
ich bezweifle sollte auf jeden fall und
rock sind dann schreiben verlinkt
vielleicht mitmachen so weit so gut
ausgehalten